Film Courage: Corey you say if you can't answer
this one question your script will be rejected?
Corey Mandell, Screenwriter and Screenwriting
Instructor: Yes, true story. I broke in the
business by selling a pitch to Ridley Scott
called Metropolis when I was in film school
and then I was flown to London to work with Ridley
to flesh out the story before I go to write it.
So it was really crazy, I mean I'm in film school
and then I'm on a plane flying first class, which
I didn't…not only have I never flown first class,
I didn't know it existed. This is how dumb I am,
they were coming by like food and alcohol and I
was like “No, no” because I can't afford any of
that. Then when I was in London someone was
like “You don't pay for that in first class,
we paid for it.” So I ate really well on the way
home but anyway I'm in London and my big thing is
I don't want Ridley to realize I'm a student and
I don't know what I'm doing and I just don't want
to get fired the first day. I want to survive one
day before I get fired. I was very freaked out. I
go into the meeting, I'm just trying to act like
I belong. I don't feel like I do but I'm trying.
Ridley Scott is a hero of mine. Anyway, we come
down to business and he's like “So Metropolis,
what's it about ?” I give him the plot overview
like if you're flipping through your DVR and
there was like a description and he said “Oh yeah,
yeah what I mean is like what's it really about,
like at its core, what's it about?” I remember
going two thoughts, oh boy I'm done. No one taught
me this in film school. I'm not even sure what
he's asking. Then the other thing is to just look
confident because I was doing a lot of improv at
the time, look confident and give an answer. I'm
like Oh, that's what you mean,” and I gave him
an answer and he's like “Oh that's interesting,
but what do you think it's really about?” Which
is a nice way of saying swinging a miss kid and I
kept giving him answers and he kept saying what do
you think it's really about and then eventually he
took mercy on me he changed the subject something
I could do we talked for a while and we were done
and then we were going to meet the next day and
my plan was first time in London in American in
London I was going to go get into trouble and see
the sites but no went back to my hotel room and
called everyone I knew in La like what's he asking
me what do I answer I don't want to get fired and
someone uh was married to a professional writer
and she was nice enough to get on the phone with
me and explain what Ridley was asking and and I'll
get to this a little bit so then I had to figure
out what what he's asking is at its core what is
the one thing the unifying thing that everything
is about and I will continue the Ridley Scott
story in a moment but I just want to impress upon
everyone listening how important this is because
I wouldn't have known this I hadn't gone through
this ordeal and now on the other side of working
with writers it it's just really clear that really
smart writers don't get this until it's explained
to them it's not it's just not intuitively obvious
so I want you to imagine a really crazy story
it's going to take a few minutes but stay with
me because it's really important imagine that you
have a friend who wants to be a professional home
builder and they have to write or build a spec
home like you have to write a spec script and sell
it or at least get someone to see their spec home
and say you're amazing I'm going to hire you to
build a home for me okay and let's say that land
is really expensive but they inherited this little
Island so they could build anywhere for free but
they only have enough money to buy enough lumber
and supplies to build one house so they can only
build one house they take you to the island and
they say where should I build it should I build a
beach house should I build a forest house should I
build a mountain house over I only have one shot
I got to sell this house where do I build it and
you say I think those are all great options you
can't go wrong with any of those and they're like
I know but what's the best you're like they're
all the best just pick one and build it you're
going to be great you run into your friend a few
years later they're just like ah I am no good at
home building I couldn't get a real estate agent
I couldn't this I suck and you're like no no you
have so much talent and they're like no I suck
and you're like can I see the house and they're
like you don't want to see the house it's it's
embarrassing I'm like no no I want to see the
house and they're like all right say take you to
the island now this is where the story gets crazy
but this is the important part imagine that your
friend for some crazy reason just couldn't decide
where to build the house so they built part of
it in the forest part of in the beach and part
of it they only had enough supplies for one house
so it's just piles of rubble part of a wall part
of a this part of so it's like pile of rubble over
here pile of rubble over here pile of rubble over
here no one wanted to buy a pile of rubble no
one looked at that pile of rubble and said oh
you're the person I want to give all my money to
to build a house for me this is what Writers Do
all the time they go wide they don't go deep what
is your story about what is the singular thing the
singular unifying experience that everything
is built on writers will build part of their
story on this and part of it on this part of it
on this and if your story is about more than one
thing it's not about anything it's not a novel
it's a screenplay it's a pilot script it's got
to be a deep exploration of one experience what is
that experience it is the most important question
that you can ask I think the best screenplay
ever written is network and it was written by
Patty C and I'm saying Patty c not to be cool or
hip but I am dyslexic and there's some names I
can't pronounce and I can't pronounce Patty's last
name and I feel bad because I butcher it so when I
say Patty c not trying to be cool I just can't
pronounce his last name I saw a video where he
said I feel sorry for the writer who doesn't know
what their story is about and he would not write
until he knew what it was about and it took them
a year to figure out what network was about which
is a question how do you live your life when you
live in a society that doesn't value human life
and everything in network is a is reflection of
that and a meditation on that and built on that
and it creates that magic cohesion and it creates
that deep emotional impact and once he knew what
it was how do you live your life when you live
in a a society that no longer values human
life he typed it on an index card and he put it
above his typewriter and it was a North star I I
trained someone who went on to work on madman same
thing Matthew weer had the what's it about on the
wall so they would always navigate toward it for
Madmen what it was about was the inherent conflict
between that which you most want to do and that
which you need to do so what you need to do but
what you want to do that inherent conflict in
everything in Mad Men every storyline and subplot
and charact it was all built on that so people
came in and they would pitch like okay season 3
what are possible storylines and you go around the
room remember throw out all these ideas there'd be
great ideas that didn't sit on that piece of land
so it wouldn't be used it's so important a TV show
to have a cohesive deep experience even if you
don't know consciously what it is like I've seen
Network five times and before that interview
I never said oh I love Netflix or Netflix no
I don't love Netflix I love Network what a
brilliant meditation and exploration on that
inherent question of how do you live your life
when you live in society that no longer values
human life I didn't see that consciously I did
but Patty did and once I heard Patty say that on
a video obviously since past I went back and read
the script and watched the movie and I was like oh
my God everything I was in Santa Monica at the AO
theater watching one of my favorite 70s film Dog
Day Afternoon and Frank Pearson the writer amazing
writer was there this a few years before he passed
away and he did questions and someone asked him
like what his writing process was so this was this
is really if you're at all interested in writing
you should really remember this so what happened
with that project is he had four months to write
a draft and there going to give it to Al Pacino
and Al Pacino would read that draft and say yes
I'm going to make this movie or no I'm not and
they weren't going to go to anyone else so it was
one shot Al paccino and this thing that Frank had
been working on for so long he had one shot and
so he had four months to write the best possible
script and someone was like what did you do and
he said well I spent three months figuring out
what the story was singularly about and one month
writing it that tells you you something that the
best writers use 75% of his scarce time to figure
this out now once what it's about it's your best
friend and your worst enemy so with Ridley Scott
every day I kept coming in and I knew what he was
asking but I couldn't get the answer it's hard and
it seemed like months of torture but it was like
five days and I finally said something he's like
write that down okay write that down he goes read
repeat it back to me and I did he'll change this
word because Precision matters and he kept having
me refine it and he looked around the room he goes
read it again looked around the room read it again
looked around the room he said will you do me a
favor and circle it oh it's circled Ridley he goes
that's what it's about and I was like wow I just
survived my first Gauntlet and everything had to
be built on that and here's why it's your worst
enemy we once we knew it was about we were really
cruising and we have almost the whole structure
but we could never come up with a great opening we
had okay openings but we all felt like we didn't
have an opening and one day rley comes in with a
skip and a step and he's like have you ever seen
Blade Runner and I didn't tell him this but I got
fired for the first and only time because of
Blade Runner so when I was a kid I lied about
my age pretending to be older so like I work in a
movie theater and it was an old dollar movie house
which they used to have and I was an usher so my
job was to sweep and do ushery stuff and what I
did is I'd come in and I'd sweep into the theater
showing Blade Runner and then I'd sit there for
eight hours and then I'd sweep my way to the time
card and go home and about three weeks later the
manager said Mandell my office want to talk to you
and I'm like okay Mr I forget his name but anyway
so I walk in in the office and he goes have a seat
and I do he goes it appears to me that I'm paying
you to watch Blade Runner every day is this true
and I'm like yeah basically and he goes why am I
paying you to do that and I'm like I don't know
and he goes you're fired and I'm like yeah I get
it so like I get it so yes I'm a fan of Blade
Runner but I didn't want to look like a weird
fanboy so I said I've seen it a couple of times
and he said so we had an opening that we loved but
we couldn't afford it we were on a pretty limited
budget but for this movie we could do it I think
with an adjustment this is our opening would you
be open to me telling you what this opening is
like oh yes Ridley I'm open to yes go ahead let's
hear it so he's pitching me this opening I'm just
writing it down and it's brilliant it's so good
and I'm I have chills because I'm like my name's
going on this script and people going think I
figured this out but I didn't this is just such
a great opening why didn't I think of this and
then he's almost done and he goes oh dang it now
we can't use it I'm like what what we can't use
it what do you mean we can't use it we can't use
it I'm like really this is awesome he yeah but
it's not connected to the what's it about and
I wanted to say the what's it about like but he
had artistic integrity like everything so when you
don't know what your story is about you're just
groping in the darkness trying to figure out what
your story is and what belongs or what doesn't
once what it's about you're going downhill in
sunlight and the light is just and the breeze
and that's great but then you're going to be
tested because you're going to have some problem
with your script something you're stuck with and
you're going to finally have a great solution but
doesn't connect to what it's about and then the
question is do you have artistic integrity or not
so it's your best friend and it's your worst enemy
now people will ask is this the same thing as a
log line no a log line is a selling tool so Vince
Gilligan's log line for Breaking Bad was it's Mr
Chips goes it's Mr Chips goes to no no I'm sorry
it's yeah it's Mr Chips become Scarface it's Mr
Chips become Scarface now that's an interesting
idea Mr Chips become Scarface tell me more let me
read the script it's interesting that's what a log
line does it can't be what it's about because not
everything is that's the Walter White Journey that
change but what about Skylar What About Saul what
about all the other characters like that can't be
what it's about no Vince Gilligan very slightly
and smartly tells you what it's about in the
second scene and the second scene of the pilot
Walter White is talking to his chemistry class
and he says what is chemistry and he says it's the
some scientific ionic bonds and this and that he
goes but that's not what it's about to me and he
looks into the camera he says this is what it's
about to me it's about the study of change that's
what the whole show is about that was the what's
it about for the entire show so I remember a
couple years ago I got a call from a student
she was just so excited and impressed she was
working at Warner Brothers and she was a creative
executive and she got invited to some meetings
that the head of Warner Brothers was taking with
very big writers and she called me and she goes
I didn't know that the head of Warner Brothers
was your student and I'm like I don't think they
were she goes no they were your student I'm like
I don't think so and well then they're stealing
your stuff and I'm like okay what's going on what
happen I'm in this room and and he's having these
means with the big writers and he's always asking
them what's it about and if they give an answer
that's not one thing is no no no it's about more
than one thing it's not about anything so if if he
didn't teach you that if you if you didn't teach
him that he stole that from you I'm like whoa,
whoa whoa whoa no I I stole it from them like
I'm teaching what the industry does the industry
is not doing what I'm teaching I learned this from
Ridley Scott and it's so so important that what
your story is about and it's a singular thing
and then you go deep and you connect everything
to it that is absolutely required if you want to
have any chance of anyone in the industry paying
attention to either your pitch or your script.